Understanding South Africa's
Genocide Case against Israel, Part two
What is genocide?
The term “genocide” didn't
exist before 1944.
That is, until this man,
a Jewish lawyer from Poland,
coined the term
to describe Nazi policies
of systematic murder.
At first
this was just a word
without any legal power.
Until in 1948, the U.N.
drafted the Genocide Convention,
which makes this an international crime,
defining genocide as:
“Killing members of a group;”
“Causing serious bodily harm or mental harm
to members of a group;”
And crucially,
“Deliberately inflicting on a group conditions of life
calculated to bring about
its physical destruction in whole or in part;”
“Deliberately.”
You have to prove that
they set out to do this,
to destroy a group of people.
every country
that has signed
has an obligation to prevent
and punish genocide wherever it happens.
And that's why
South Africa filed this case.
They see that genocide
is happening in Gaza
and it is their duty
to call it out In part three,
I will dive into this 84 page document,
the evidence South Africa
is using in this case.